do kids ever recognize you as Buzz
Lightyear cuz your voice what what's
unusual it's the voice and I think
Warner Brothers cartoons a long time ago
told them people they did not want Mel
Blanc or anybody doing the voice outside
of the cartoon environment and I
understand why I'm in Manhattan in an
elevator and a young kid is misbehaving
some kids at certain days just punch you
in the crotch I don't know what that's
about
there's a certain age that right there
they know it gets your attention and so
this kid was punching mom and did the
leg and really going nuts so I said oh
infinity and beyond you shouldn't treat
your mom like that and the kid would
[Laughter]
crying and the moms looking at me like
now she's mad at you and the kid goes
that ugly man swallowed Buzz Lightyear
now you can punch him I will say Hanks
my good buddy when it plays Woody but
who cares about a cowboy he goes he did
a sweet trick for us we went to a
Children's Hospital together and we did
and what he did it was such a wonderful
idea he has these kids close your eyes
for a minute and when the kids close
their eyes then we can do the voices
together and then they imagine Woody and
Buzz are there it's much oh god he's a
great guy and I said was it I've learned
that lesson if anybody wants to hear it
shut your eyes he's pretty little kids
little shut your eyes and then I'll go
to the knee room say some Buzz Lightyear
stuff then they don't don't freak him
out and an elevator subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe my
channel
please don't make me keep going